resultado 131 votos afirmativos 117
negativos
a pensiones resulta afirmativo cánticos
de aborto legal abrazos y lágrimas la
marea verde celebra con vítores del
resultado de la votación del proyecto de
ley sobre la interrupción voluntaria del
embarazo después de más de 20 horas de
intenso debate legislativo ahora la
última palabra para la despenalización
del aborto en argentina la tiene el
senado la sección de diputados dijeron
que los votos estarían en el senado
porque el dictamen que salió ahora con
la media sanción está hablado también
con senadores entonces por lo que
dijeron los mismos diputados tendríamos
un buen resultado también en el senado
un obstáculo que las feministas de la
campaña nacional por el derecho legal
seguro y gratuito saben que no será
fácil debido a la fuerte presión de los
grupos religiosos y conservadores en el
senado cuyos miembros representan las
provincias y por el apoyo de los
activistas anti derechos celestes algo
que refleja las divisiones que este tema
ha hecho salir a flote en argentina
donde también muchas mujeres compañeros
celestes se han manifestado en contra de
la ley el proyecto impulsado por la
presidencia contempla la final
del aborto hasta la semana 14 del
embarazo además los profesionales que
intervengan en la interrupción del
embarazo tendrán derecho a ejercer la
objeción de conciencia pero deberán
derivar de buena fe a la paciente a otro
profesional una cláusula que los
pañuelos verdes no aprueban no estamos
de acuerdo
de hecho nosotros creemos que eso sirve
solo para obturar en algunos lugares que
se efectivicen pero bueno seguiremos
dando vueltas militancia por otra parte
con una amplia mayoría los legisladores
aprobaron el plan de los mil días de
protección integral de la mujer
embarazada hasta los tres primeros años
de infancia el feminismo argentino
confía que el derecho a la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo sea una realidad
antes de fin de año